you know it wasn't until I got to the
jungle that people were willing to show
me into this on the dimension that
exceeded my wildest dreams I mean that's
it and my dreams are pretty wild and
they were then and I'm sure yours are as
well and yet even if we dream together
we cannot dream the frontiers of what is
possible because in our world of entropy
and tawdriness and betrayal and
stupidity there is also you know the
unspeakably improbable presence of this
thing in these plans and you know I
believe it called us forth out of
primate organization I believe that
history is an an effort to come to terms
with this a kind of hysterical love
affair with the unthinkable where you
know you embrace it for a thousand years
then you burn all your cities and books
and persecute it for a thousand years
and then you go mad and flip the coin
eeeh because it's here with us it is
with us tangible experience and yet not
rationally apprehend about it is the
confounding of rationalism and
rationalism is the weapon by which the
ego segregates the world me and them
inside outside my tribe their tribe the
good people the bad people this
segregation of the ego this is the
neurotic response that somehow comes out
of the trauma of our evolution on the
planet our mother has been turbulent our
childhood was turbulent ievo k-- this
this morning when I talked about how
nine times the glaciers rolled south
from the poles I mean we were left alone
in the apartment a lot is the
practically
equivalent of this so now finding our
way back we can't get out of this mess
without a miracle I mean it's like the
Grateful Dead saying you know you need a
miracle every day and the only miracle
around seems to lie in this strange
domain of this shamanic dimension that
against all odds and probability there
is Hell or something nearby
anyway the strange flickering light of
an unvisited farmhouse and we're broken
down on the road with a double flat and
rain is pouring so we are going to have
to make our way toward this thing which
beckons and which seems to have shaped
our history and these Amazonian people
kept the faith during the prodigal
wanderings of Western man through
history the Amazon peoples kept this
faith which the memory of which they had
carried over the land bridge from the
Eurasian continent the oldest religion
in history the doorway out of ordinary
time and into the presence of the elder
things whatever they may be we don't
even know our history is a fiction spun
so thin that we are like children in the
face of this possibility
HP Lovecraft where are you now that we
need you I personally felt that I
searched the surface of reality like a
blind person probing for a [ __ ] an
opening a possibility and the seamless
surface of the high walls that seemed to
Canlis in the prison of Gnostic iron
that the man Dian's placed at the center
of the universe and the [ __ ] in the
armor is this radiant other mnestheus
showing through the plans and what it is
who knows what it's for who knows but
that it loves us that it too
is reaching up toward us is self-evident
and how can we not respond to that
we don't know what reality is we don't
know who we are we don't know where we
are we are lost and this is beckoning
light warmth affection and understanding
for the plight of humanity shamans have
always healed their people and predicted
the weather and predicted the movement
of game and this sort of thing out of
resonance with this greater mind in
nature which has sheltered the human
family over millennia I mean it is the
unseen partner it is the goddess it's a
real thing and now it must somehow be
invoked operationally again because of
our predicament as a result of having
turned away from that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]